now if you are interested
in reducing the amount of alcohol you
are addicted i'm sorry craving
this video is for you now there's many
reasons why people drink alcohol reduce
stress
uh maybe for health reasons which i did
a video on that there is
zero health benefit to drinking alcohol
now in the liver you have
a couple different enzymes that break
down alcohol now the first one takes
ethanol
and turns it into a toxic material
called acetyl aldehyde which is the
chemical that causes damage to your
cells it's the chemical that gives you a
hangover that makes you feel kind of
funky and then there are other enzymes
to break it down further into acetic
acid which is actually vinegar so in
your body the liver turns alcohol
into vinegar which is interesting and
vinegar is non-toxic for your liver
so there's a natural remedy that has
virtually no side effects that can help
reduce or prevent the consumption of
alcohol it's very studied with
significant results it's been around
since at least
600 a.d which was used in chinese
medicine but the effect on alcohol to
the liver
is not good it depletes your vitamin b1
which gives you a whole series of
additional side effects it can increase
your risk for getting cancer it
increases fat on your liver
inflammation on your liver increases
your risk of getting cirrhosis which is
scar tissue on your liver and it
increases estrogen in the body so
the more estrogen the less testosterone
you're going to have and so this natural
herb is called kutsu
and kutsu is that plant that you see on
the side of the road
that literally covers
trees and
fences and so this plant kutsu is in the
legume family and i've been looking at
it as an alternative source to feed my
farm animals
because it's very very high in nitrogen
and protein it's like 26 protein and
even humans can eat it they can put in
their salad or they can take it as an
extract it's also really good to put in
your compost as the green manure because
it's very very high in nitrogen so it
can act as an organic
slow releasing nitrogen to make your
plants grow really well and really spike
the chlorophyll content but
you can also use it to help reduce your
craving for alcohol in one study this is
a placebo placebo-controlled
double-blinded study
and it was done in mice
they showed just one dose okay two grams
of kutsu within two and a half hours
produced a significant decrease
in the desire to drink
alcohol now the chinese translation of
kutsu
means
drunkenness dispeller or make less drunk
so kutsu has these very special
phytonutrients that's involved in the
breakdown
of
ethanol very similar to certain
medications they use to help people
curb the appetite for alcohol but
without the side effects so when you
consume this extract or consume the leaf
in a salad you will not only desire less
alcohol
but you will have less toxic effect from
alcohol in fact you'll probably find
that you won't get a hangover so a
couple ways to apply this
you can take katsu extract
before you go to a social event or a few
hours before you're going to drink and
you're going to find that you're just
not going to have that desire as much
now kutsu also works on the
neurotransmitters in your brain
gaba
dopamine which are both directly
involved in addiction and there's also
one study i found that you can use kutsu
to help reduce the addiction or cravings
for even cocaine if you have a problem
with that but kutsu is totally edible
you can use it as a green very similar
to eating swiss chard for example where
you're going to cook it
you'll still get the benefits
so on that note that's your remedy to
help reduce the amount of alcohol and if
you haven't seen my other video on how
to repair your liver using natural foods
i put that up right here check it out